الرئيس التركي وصف الانفجار في اسطنبول
بالهجوم ووعد بمحاسبه المتورطين واعلن
مقتل عدد من الاشخاص واصابه اكثر من 50
اخرين
ارهابي لكن التطورات الاوليه والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الاوليه من محافظه اسطنبول
تفوح منها رائحه الارهاب وتظهر نتائج
الاوليه وسط الفوضى وفراري الناس وما الى
ذلك ان امراه لعبت دورا في الانفجار حسنا
الانفجار بعد الظهر في واحد من اكثر
الشوارع ازدحاما في مدينه اسطنبول خلال
مسير الناس او نزهتهم فجاه
بدا الناس بالفراغ سيارات الاسعاف هرعت
الى مكان الحادث كما حضرت سيارات الاطفاء
وفرق تفكيك المتفجرات
وقامت الشرطه بتطويق المكان واغلاق
المداخل الى شارع الاستقلال
وبدا المحققون بعملهم في مكان الحادث حسب
وسائل اعلام المحليه
هذا الشارع السياحي الشهير يقع وسط
المدينه في منطقه تقسيم ويمشي فيه ملايين
الاشخاص بشكل يومي كثيرا منهم من السياح
سبق ان تعرض شارع الاستقلال الى سلسله من
الهجمات الارهابيه عام 2015 و2016 اتمنى
انها تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه